wir dulden keine antidemokratische hetze
und keine herabwürdigung der
bundesrepublik deutschland im bundestag
rechtsextremistische pöbeleien und
gewalt bei der demonstration am
vergangenen samstag in berlin haben zu
recht viele menschen erschreckt und
empört wir werden solche ausschreitungen
nicht hinnehmen wer sich über die korona
maßnahmen ärgert oder ihre notwendigkeit
anzweifelt kann und darf dagegen
demonstrieren
mein verständnis endet aber dort wo
demonstranten sich vor den karren von
demokratie feinden und politischen
hetzern spannen lassen der auf den
straßen den schulterschluss mit
rechtsextremisten sucht aber auch wer
nur gleichgültig neben neonazis fremden
feinden und antisemiten herläuft
wer sich nicht eindeutig und aktiv
abgrenzt macht sich mit ihnen gemeinden
die gewaltausschreitungen am samstag
haben wieder einmal deutlich gezeigt der
rechtsextremismus hat tiefgreifende
wurzeln in unserer gesellschaft
er ist eine ernste gefahren ihn wirksam
zu bekämpfen
seine umtriebe in den netzen frühzeitig
aufzudecken
das ist eine wichtige und anderen de
aufgabe die sicherheitsbehörden polizei
wie verfassungsschutz müssen für diese
fundamental wichtige arbeit darum die
notwendige unterstützung erhalten und
gut ausgestattet sein
allerdings meine damen und herren die
verteidigung der freiheitlichen
demokratie obliegt nicht allein der
polizei
sie ist aufgabe und pflicht der gesamten
gesellschaft und eines jeden einzelnen
aktiv entschieden
und mutig müssen wir gemeinsam den
feinden unserer demokratie die stirn
bieten
wer die verstörenden bilder von samstag
gesehen hat der musste noch schlimmeres
befürchten dass die gewalt nicht
hingenommen wurde haben wir ihnen zu
verdanken der polizei berlins der
polizei anderer länder und des bundes
den vielen tausend polizeibeamtinnen und
beamten die am samstag unter hohem
persönlichen risiko man mit großer
professionalität recht und gesetz
verteidigt haben unsere demokratie liebt
und kann sich ihrer feinde erwehren sie
die polizistinnen und polizisten haben
dafür gesorgt dass zehntausende menschen
der grundrechte auf meinungs- und
versammlungsfreiheit ausüben konnten
wirksam und beherzt aber ebenso maßvoll
und angemessen haben sie gezeigt dass
unser rechtsstaat funktioniert als aber
die auflagen willentlich und wissentlich
missachtet wurden und demonstranten zur
gewalt aufriefen haben sie und der
äußerst schwierigen bedingungen die
demonstration aufgelöst und das recht
durchgesetzt
für ihren einsatz ihr vorbildliches
verhalten gebührt ihnen den
polizistinnen und polizisten
großer dank respekt und anerkennung
vielen dank auch in vers kommen